So,
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
picking up where we left off
yesterday morning
in
the book of purification
chapters of wudoo.
The subchapter regarding the preferred
times, occasions, instances in which a
person is encouraged to make wudoo.
We mentioned previously two things.
Number one, any remembrance of Allah.
Number two, for the occasion of sleep.
The third thing that the author mentions
here is al junup
a person in a state of jeneva jeneba
meaning
meaning major hadith major sexual
impurity.
And so if a person is in a state of
janaba, it is the sunnah that the person
make woo
for one of four things that they wish to
do. Number one to eat. Number two to
drink. Number three to sleep. Number
four to have relations a second time.
These four things the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam in janaba
would make wudoo for
so let's imagine the scenario here a
person has
say relations with his or her spouse and
then
afterward the person wishes to eat
something or drink something or sleep or
have relations a second time
then it is the sunnah to make for these
occasions.
[Silence]
tells us in Muslim
that the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's
habitual practice
is that if he was in a state of janaba
and he wished to eat something or drink
something or sleep, he would make wudoo
as he would for salah. The same woo as
he would for salah. And a person may
say, why the same woo as he would for
salah? Why not just say wudoo?
Is there any other kind of woodoo?
Are there multiple types of woodoo? Does
the woodoo for salah differ in any way
from wudoo for sleeping or eating or?
It doesn't. But the reason she says this
is because wudoo in the Arabic language
means to wash
generally linguistically.
And this is why sometimes
the
in in some narrations or in some
instances
it will be mentioned that someone made
wudoo meaning wash their hands. So in
the Arabic language linguistically means
to wash
and it comes from
and it's the same etmology as a boat.
A boat.
[Silence]
And that is because they share etmology.
So we just switch the two letters in
their places. This is something that is
very common in the Arabic language. And
so it's originally taken from light a
boat light. And that is because the idea
is that when somebody washes something,
it becomes what? Shiny. Right? It
shines.
Something that is clean shines.
Something that is dirty is
conceptualized as being dull. And so
this is why it's referred to as woo. But
then aloo
in the legislation of Islam then takes
on an additional meaning and that is a
very specific ritual of washing for
prayer.
And so Aisha here is saying,
well, that could be meant
linguistically, meaning he would wash
his hands, which makes sense, right? Or
legislatively,
which means he made so she says,
"So that you know, the listener knows
what kind of she's speaking about." Is
that clear? Yeah.
[Silence]
narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam said, "If any of you has relations
with his family, with his wife, with
his spouse, and then wishes to
have relations a second time, meaning
without having madeul, they're still in
a state of janaba, then he should make
wuboo." And this could mean wash his
hands or wash up or it could mean make
woo for salah. So which one do we take?
Well, when it's in the Quran or in the
sunnah, what's meant is the legislative
sense,
right?
So if a poet a poet says the word heart
you know the heart
and a doctor says the heart
those mean two different things right
for a poet we expect the heart to not be
meant in the medical sense to be meant
in the in the metaphorical sense the
emotion center emotionally.
Whereas for a doctor who says the heart,
we don't he's not we don't take his
words to mean metaphorically heart. We
take his words to mean the actual
organ in the body that pumps blood.
Right? So
dependent on the speaker is how we
interpret
words that share commonalities amongst
fields.
When it's the prophet speaking then we
always take it to mean legislative sense
unless there's some evidence to the
counter. And when an Arab is speaking
then we always take it to mean in the
Arabic sense unless something in the
context
points to the counter
subala
[Arabic recitation]